you know I love keeping you abreast of
different scams and there has been no
greater scam in the covet era than this
urine drinker urine injector urine
nebulizer Christopher key the if the
name rings a bell you may remember that
we covered this guy anti-vaxx leader
urges followers to drink their own urine
to fight covid
um that is not actually recommended
medically you should not drink your own
urine to fight covid anyway he now says
he invented a hologram sticker where he
stores information and it has something
to do with an energy field and it can
relieve pain if you put it in the right
spot now here's my question about this
who is stupid enough to fall for this
stuff
and I know that it's very easy to say
if you're dumb enough to fall for this
then you deserve it right a fool in
their money are soon parted or whatever
the case may be
but it's hard for me to believe anyone
with normal cognitive function would
fall for this so then I start to wonder
are the only people that fall for this
those who are cognitively limited and
actually do need to be protected from
charlatans like this I don't know let's
think about that as we listen to what
this guy explained and I will send you
the
you live it when it doesn't work for
somebody because then I want to go back
to the lab and try to figure out why God
Made You different this little chip is a
hologram where we're able to store
information into the Hologram and then
we put in the energy field it resonates
and when I took this to my professors at
Alabama many years ago and they did the
clinical study on so like Christopher
how in the world is this doing this it's
nothing but a sticker guys it's not just
a sticker it is energy it is frequency
everything is frequency everything is
okay so
I can't imagine there's a single person
in what I call my core audience like I
get that there are people who hate watch
from all walks of life okay but the
people in my core audience people who
like subscribe to the audio podcast and
you know not met me maybe not every
episode but like three times a week you
listen to the show when you're at the
gym or whatever the case may be I can't
imagine there's a single person in my
audience that would fall for this and
our audience at this point is sizable
where are the people that fall for this
are they of normal cognitive function
and if the answer is no then isn't what
this guy is doing particularly
disgusting and particularly predatory
and of course I have the same questions
that often come up if he mentions God if
God made you a little different then we
just have to tweak the sticker to get it
to do the thing why wouldn't God just
prevent you from needing the sticker in
the first place why wouldn't God just
cure your pain why isn't prayer enough
why do you need this guy's sticker with
the energy field and whatever the case
may be now when I look at the sticker I
I can tell you why the sticker won't
work it doesn't have liquid silver in it
of course
that's a joke but that's the the main
question I bring to you
is who would actually fall for this I
don't I know a lot of people who don't
have formal education I know a lot of
people that I don't consider to be the
smartest people none of them would fall
for something like this or that you're
in drinking who are the people that
would how many of them are there and
quite frankly do they need to be
protected from charlatans like this